there's some big border drama happening
in South America right now the
government of Venezuela just had this
ceremony where they released this new
map the map claims all of this land land
which is a part of the sovereign country
of Guyana like they're claiming well
over half of guyana's territory what is
going on here well there are two answers
the first one is the British back in
1899 the British and Venezuela agreed on
this border but Venezuela now says that
that was a biased decision and that it
was actually just Colonial shenanigans
by the US and the UK and that actually
this is their land but the real answer
here is oil in 2015 they discovered a
massive oil deposit right off of the
coast of Guyana they're making a billion
bucks a year off this Venezuela wants
this oil and they think they have a
claim to all of this land and so they're
going to fight for it Guyana obviously
is not letting this happen they're going
to fight about it it's going to be a
thing I'm going to keep following it if
you want to better understand global
politics follow along for more